haciendo hincapié en un frente unido
contra las ambiciones nucleares de
teherán el secretario de estado
estadounidense anthony blinken y su
homólogo israelí yair lapid reconocieron
sus diferencias sobre las negociaciones
nucleares con irán mientras las
potencias mundiales manejan un nuevo
acuerdo
en
el diálogo forma parte de la solidez de
nuestra amistad en israel y eeuu
seguirán trabajando juntos para evitar
un irán nuclear trident nuclear eeuu
quiere volver al acuerdo de 2015 del que
la administración trump se retiró pero
israel dice que su renegociación no es
suficiente para frenar la amenaza iraní
dwayne kemp busca tranquilizar a los
estados árabes ya israel asegurando que
su país está comprometido con la
seguridad de la nación esto en medio de
la preocupación de que washington esté
prestando menos atención a oriente medio
ya que las relaciones con china y rusia
son prioritarias la pasada
administración de donald trump me dio
los llamados acuerdos de abraham que
supusieron la normalización de lazos
diplomáticos de emiratos árabes unidos
bahrein y marruecos con israel
representantes de estos tres estados
llegaron a negro para dos días de una
cumbre sin precedentes oportunidad de
ver qué resultados concretos pueden
surgir del acuerdo también asiste egipto
y blinken dijo que espera que otros
países de la región se unan a ellos esto
mientras la pacificación con los
palestinos sigue estancada la
normalización se está convirtiendo en la
normalidad de esta región y está
permitiendo que nuestros esfuerzos
avancen a una agenda positiva que
beneficiará la vida de nuestros pueblos
invertir en infraestructuras desarrollar
energías renovables a través de estos
esfuerzos buscaremos aprovechar la
creciente normalización para atraer a
otros al tiempo que forjamos mejoras
tangibles en la vida de los palestinos
el desarrollo de nuevos lazos
energéticos es otro punto importante ya
que los países que dependen del gas ruso
empiezan a buscar el suministro en los
estados del golfo